même s'il pense ne pas activer parce
qu'il est centriste il clive forcément
et il pousse le débat aux extrêmes d'une
certaine façon la radicalité elle est là
parce qu'il est radical lui dans sa
façon de gérer les affaires l'auto
l'autocrate macron qui s'est dévoilée à
l'aune de la crise du coc vide tout
gérer en conseil de défense sous le
sceau du secret défense c'est pas ça la
démocratie française le fait qu'il a
toujours à peu près peut-être que mon
parti je me servais le temps dans les
rassure c'est pas rassurant parce que
derrière c'est quoi c'est la négation du
parlement que ce soit le sénat où
l'assemblée nationale c'est le gouverner
par décrets on en connaissait le 49-3
évidemment et puis gouverner seul sur
tout et ça pourquoi cet homme qui a été
élu très mal face à marine le pen pense
qu'il peut gouverner seul et qu'il est
le seul à avoir l'alpha et l'oméga de la
pensée politique et que ce qu'il fait
est bon pour le pays il est bon pour les
plus riches on l'a vu c'est le président
des riches lisf qui a été supprimé mais
aujourd'hui l'inflation qui est la la la
hausse de l'énergie c'est les plus
pauvres qui vont le payer